so Kanye West gave a long stream of
consciousness talk in the White House
recently and was roundly attacked for
but if you listen carefully
there were some insightful points that
he made and some important questions
including whether black Americans ought
to be monolithically loyal to the
Democratic Party why should they be
that's a question other people are
asking as well star Parker is one of
them she's founder and president of the
Center for urban renewal and education
she just sort of peace suggesting that
as Democrats have moved laughed on
religion and social policy even the rule
of law itself they could continue to
alienate some conservative minded black
voters star Parker joins us tonight
Strutt parker thank you very much for
coming on yeah well so there was a
simple question first
why should African Americans who for
generations have been very loyal to the
Democratic Party rethink that loyalty
well they've been loyal to the
Democratic Party because blacks have
bought this idea of activist government
but something very exciting is happening
now with Trump in office the Trump
administration is focusing on urban
communities and initiatives so we have
two things happening right now there are
very very exciting number one
african-american Millennials those that
canina with her are motivating those to
Canada so and are motivated to say wait
a minute
what are Democrats done for us we're
first of all the Millennial does not buy
this racism behind every rock narrative
of the of the Democrat Party because
their friends are diverse they've grown
up in a in a society post-civil rights
era so they don't know that world at all
but secondly their individualist they
like uniqueness we can see that in the
tattoos that they wear and so this whole
idea of collectivism and big government
doesn't work for them as well but what's
also happened is you have that baby boom
black the baby bloom black is more
traditional in their worldview so now
the Democrat Party has become so extreme
to the left so progressive that is
conflicting with that baby boom blacks
worldview and values and their concern
about their grandchildren or what
they're learning in school so we'll see
how it all plays out we're looking very
closely our group is looking very
closely at at Wisconsin at Michigan when
we're talking about the Senate seats
when we're talking about the governor
seats we should all be looking at
Georgia we should look at Florida and
then even to some degree on Maryland so
I'm very excited about the show mint if
you're an African
American voter and your family has been
in this country for 400 years a long
time in a lot of cases and all of a
sudden your party is telling you that
the real concern is people who aren't
even here legally foreign nationals from
other countries do you ask yourself at
some point but you know but what about
me the American citizen right does that
turn off voters at a certain point it's
not only turning them off that they that
this hijacking of the civil rights
movement is taking place for legal
minorities but illegals are even more
frustrating because now you're looking
at an environment to where you have that
low-wage worker competing for jobs in
communities and against people who will
not speak English so now it's not only
affecting the the real low wage its
effect in the middle class because if
you want to work in any type of public
service for the fire for the police for
the for the teachers anything you have
to be bilingual and this is making a
tremendous impact on African Americans
to rethink who these new arrivals are
and why they I think it's a totally fair
question I've never even thought about
the bilingual question but it's a real
job that you can't even in California
for instance you can take the driver's
license test in 40 languages so why do I
never hear Maxine Waters or any member
of the CBC mentioned that why because
they're very invested in progressivism
it's their job to make sure blacks do
not get any of this information they're
there the whole Congressional Black
Caucus is similar to the overseer during
slavery they had to make sure that no
slave gets any information of freedom
and that's been their role for the last
50 years what's happening now with the
Internet is people are getting more
information if I keep in my organization
urban cure we have our own new site
black community news calm so people are
getting other sources of news and
they're finding out the truth what
President Trump has said lately about
fake news is very real so there are many
instruments now competing against that
to the mainstream media so that we can
get other information and blacks are
hearing those messages start Parker
thank you for joining us you're welcome